either reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey listen guys one of our
top of work tears that our patron pages
whatever video you requested was
definitely doing put up on the youtubes
today comes from a man named Eric
Horseman who is requested from
watchmojo.com top ten best movies I've
seen all 50 let's do this he's calling
Mandy a horror movie
I wouldn't say straight up but I would
say Horrors definitely one of its John I
would put it like second or third grade
that's not an action movie I'm a horror
movie yeah it's not like at all I would
say there's horror in it but it would be
like the pork it's not a genre
implant sending him on a mission to
avenge his murdered wife condition to
operate independently can't wait to
watch this again
my character also brings a sense of
unpredictable terror to the equation
that recalls number nine unsane I heard
this is great cliff Floyd had a
phenomenal year in 2018 winning a
Primetime Emmy for the crown and earning
widespread praise for her supporting
role in first man she gave one of her
most underrated performances in this
psychological horror story which
director Steven Soderbergh boldly shot
on an iPhone as lawyer boy plays a
troubled woman who damned jeff fretts
dressed when she's in explicably in
prison in a mental institution I know
this is my neurosis colluding with my
imagination to manifest my worst fears
well the film is grounded in reality it
feels as if Sawyer has been plummeted
down the rabbit hole coming down the
rabbit hole now this is a horror action
which also took place
[Music]
[Laughter]
you should have exactly happens
throughout the twisted tale
we can't describe the emotions it evokes
a change from unsettling to bizarrely
entrancing akin to the works of Darren
Aronofsky and David Lynch film this out
there might not be forever and all of
the seven interest movie goers though
it's an experience unlike anything else
you'll see all year
this is the one I'm disappointed for not
take on films like The Last House on the
left and I Spit on Your Grave the story
follows a woman must survive a hellish
desert after being raped and literally
pushed to the brink of death the title
suggests she also takes out the ones who
left her for dead in a gripping tale of
revenge although this material could
have easily verged into exploitation
comedy found joss stone never comes off
as manipulative it's an empowering
representation of women that doesn't shy
away from uncompromising violence number
5 annihilation to the unknown an
ovulation starts off as a creature
feature reminiscent of the thing nothing
is as it seems in this enigmatic
environment however then it becomes
[ __ ] hard to follow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Annihilation gets Garland the freedom to
explore a new world that's both
intimidating and strangely biting
although the phone setting is overrun
with physical monsters it's the inner
demons our characters face that truly
get under our skin banding is like a
wild LSD trip that it submerges the
viewer into a whacked-out state and if
that's not enough for you read sets out
on bloodthirsty quest to exact revenge
really only utilizing dark shadows and
red lighting to create hell on earth how
I hope you miss I think hereditary is
gonna be number one once they flip them
around for audience satisfaction
[Music]
when the return of Jamie Lee Curtis old
woman Lauri without feeling scale once
again
read Connie much of the established
continuity you fortunately don't need to
see the other sequels to follow this
chilling humorous and well-crafted
thrill ride that's equal parts of maj
and spiritual successor yes hereditary
is gonna be number one unless they get
really out there with it yeah it's an
honorable mention yeah the audience with
anxiety whether it's the breaking of a
glass frame or the plate sound of a
children's toy
[Music]
not only in a revelation of sound design
but also elector de force in visual
storytelling taking full advantage of
the harrowing premise the filmmakers
convey an emotional story through
expressive performances clever
foreshadowing and an effective use of
American Sign Language becoming a
box-office hit and critical favorite few
horror films yeah really yeah jump
scared it was a famous good atmosphere
for sure crops corn hardy
[Laughter]
[Music]
without resorting to jump scares for
other cheap tactics this film is
petrifying on multiple levels for
starters it's a psychological mind
bender that tackles grief and mental
illness while blurring the lines between
reality and insanity all it contains
some of the most graphic imagery of
recent memory it doesn't take much more
than an intense
precision between army characters to
send us into shock it all builds to an
ending that will leave you disturbed
haunted and trying to decipher what the
hell just happened so we're gonna show
you right now list not bad list it's the
only move list you can I guess so yeah
with being satisfying to anybody I feel
like oh there are always a ton that come
out every year and I'm always kicking
myself for not having seen like a bunch
of the smaller one dead people like what
are some smaller ones that have come out
that well yeah the why I couldn't tell
you cuz I haven't had a very good finger
on that pulse but every year it's like
when I was working at blow my house I
had a much better idea of like oh [ __ ]
they're all these horror movies I didn't
get to see this here you don't yeah and
there are often a lot of smaller ones
that are great that get overlooked
because they don't have the reach sure
all right so let's only talk about the
ones we haven't seen because that's what
I feel like our commentary would have
its most strength really shine I'm sorry
I just don't think upgrade is a horror
movie yeah I don't have seen it having
like underlying horror elements does not
quality just doesn't qualify as a horror
movie to me I wouldn't even think that
great on this list I just wouldn't think
that I get where they're coming from
it's like if I saw upgrade in the horror
section of a video store I would be like
not dead on but sure why not cuz it's
pulpy its gory there is a body horror
element and there is a sinister vibe to
the future so yeah well I agree with you
ultimately the cyberpunk action thriller
is the genre I would put that under I
get how there's horror in it and for the
number-10 pic I just like this movie
enough that I'm like sure put it on your
list why not but you know it's not a
through-and-through horror flick you
know what John you're right when you're
right you're right you know what this
time I gotta give it to you I say you're
right to me upgrade just kind of seems
like because the son of the Blum House
umbrella and also with Leigh Whannell
directing it that a lot of people were
under the impression that it might but
not even the trailer advertises it like
a horror movie you know not what they
own no no no I have not seen unsane
which everyone talks about it being shot
on an iPhone as if that's all he did
he invented that [ __ ] tangerine they
just do it like we only had an iPhone oh
yeah I'm sure they had people with sound
and lighting and a cinematographer and
everything I'm sure it was bare but I'm
sure it wasn't just not some people talk
about it as if it was just the iPhone
and that's what makes it so special and
how they did it I see all the footage
they clearly had a whole crew here is
the best way to make overlord you got to
check out our movie route for that I was
actually genuinely surprised by the
actual horror in it I thought it might
just be some schlocky campy ass B movie
which it has its elements of that but
for the most part I thought it was a
very effective horror war movie to me
it's very underrated maybe because they
put it out after all it's always like
people home behind it going
I'm surprised perform well why it came
out like a week after Halloween that's
right when people want to stop watching
horror movies yeah cheering August
October yeah well that's all the way
stuff people are like let's take a break
from horror I thought this could have
killed it maybe a little bit earlier or
something cuz yeah like I love the way
that that movie even starts out the
horror is just war before it even
becomes anything sci-fi and I feel like
I'm I hope for that movie is that it'll
pick up a cult life of some kind because
it's pretty fun it probably will John it
probably will Suspiria shame on you
yeah I watched this year I watched
original I can't wait to watch this
shame yeah I am very anticipatory of its
still even I've heard a lot of very new
it it probably would have been better to
watch in the theaters than at home
very much so because it's almost three
hours long and that's always an easier
experience and the theatres and it is at
home but I've heard it's really out
there and it does a lot of its own
things and I feel like even if it's not
something that I end up loving I
probably would appreciate it
my girlfriend watched the movie revenge
I thought we were supposed to watch that
together baby you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I guess I couldn't come over one night
and she had a free t-mobile rental at
the red box like this is the only move
and then she was like I wanted to watch
it so she watched it we were actually
just talking about where JT in April the
other day cuz they loved the movie and I
am like this is one of those movies like
I really wish I caught in the theaters I
know it's directed by a woman and
whenever people were saying it's not
this like hyper sexualized thing it's
not through the 12 year-old boys yeah
look how cou naxi man directed this
story because I'm kind of sick of that
trope of woman gets raped and then
suddenly she's badass but apparently
this movie handles it in a different
type of way that doesn't make it
insulting very very very curious ya
heard a few mixed things mostly very
positive and this is like raver hinges
of genre where every single installment
I'm just like I'm gonna have to take
this one case-by-case annihilation I
probably put a little bit higher on the
I think it's like one of the better
films but in terms of a horror movie I
think because of how confusing it is and
maybe you're one of the people who's so
smart that caught on to every little
thing I think most people were including
ourselves were towards the end like what
is happening I don't know exactly can we
could go online and see what Alex
Garland has to say and then knowing what
it was about was awesome but part of
that real confusing terrain I thought
should take away some of the horror
because instead of being scared I'm more
like what feel like I'm the opposite end
of the coin from you where I'm like that
much sort of what makes it that much
more disconcerting for me oh really yeah
at least in the handling there are other
movies that have that same rag I mean
I'll give it to them though that one of
the scariest scenes I've experienced all
year does come in the scene of the
screaming bear thingy yeah that they
tease here that is one of the scariest
scenes I've experienced all year so I'll
give it to them Mandy I see I feel like
there's way more of an argument for
Mandy to be on this listen upgrade
because hence why it's Mandy to me isn't
a scary film it's got its tension and
whatever it is a nightmare I don't think
it's scary no I mean there are moments
here and there that are very jarring
visually especially when you have like
the kidnapping scene with the bikers and
all that yeah it's like there are
definitely elements of horror film
making at hand but especially when it
shifts gears it becomes very action yeah
there's another movie where I wouldn't
bulk if I saw it on the end cap of a
horror section because it's in the stew
but yeah I don't think it's a spot-on
genre lady yeah but it's a great film
we've done reviews for most of these
movies like the ones were talking about
we've reviewed on the channel Halloween
weirdly the one horror movie we haven't
talked this is a movie I really want to
go back and re-watch I remember really
enjoying it and I still hold a lot of
those feelings and I feel like movies
like this that have an especially high
standard to live up to or some kind of
hype to satisfy you know it's like we're
coming back
we're retconning a lot of the series at
large and it has to be a certain level
of great to satisfy everybody and I feel
like there's a certain amount of like
spell we're all under for the first
viewing so I'm curious to go back for it
but I do think that it deserves a place
on this list of from where I am now I
really like this movie a lot I might
even put it on my top 10 list for this
year there was kind of a backlash like
some audiences Ruolin did not care for
this because of like the humorous tones
infused in it and stuff like that which
I think really detracted for a lot of
people but I still think the finale is
one of them not scariest but one of the
most tense experiences I've had all year
that whole finale this definitely proves
you can still do a very effective and
very lucid slasher movie that isn't just
you know a bunch of silly tropes I do
think number two and one are the best
horror movies of the year I mean I and I
haven't seen a couple of them like
Suspiria or whatever but a quiet place
was
that that made an impact this amazing
sanely unique that it's easy to pinpoint
- yeah like easier than hereditary
hereditary I see why people consider
that number one I see why people love
hereditary the most cuz it's arguably
the better film but in terms of
pinpointing what makes a quiet place so
unique it's so pennpoint I just watching
the trailers oh yes the - the one-two
punch of a quiet place and then
hereditary is like this is the studio
version and then hereditary is like the
gourmet thing yeah and yeah quiet place
was one of the most unique viewing
experiences I had all year because it's
I mean a like they said it's a really
well told visual story it's really
thought out for the most part I mean
when you start picking at some of the
logistics of just the setup sure you can
find holes just the execution and the
amount of silence and tension and like
the weird way it brought the whole
audience together was super unique they
did talk about not wanting like some
people have criticized like why would
she have a baby at this point yeah and I
and I actually thought about it because
I that used to be my argument against
the movie as well well do they know how
to do abortions sure they could have
found some condoms we got to find out
the swipe companions not even a
guarantee I mean no but you could just
as easily sell me the fact that like
they practiced safe sex in the
apocalypse and it worked I don't know
yeah it would be more context but there
was no scene where they said I want to
have a child let's get pregnant and
everyone kind of treats it that way and
how do we know that it wasn't just an
accident yeah all we know is that in the
lapse of time yeah happy yeah exactly
he's so but yeah hereditary that's a
movie that sticks with you whether or
not you love it or you don't I think
it's a movie that sticks with you I
don't think you could just watch it and
be like yeah yeah even if you don't wind
up liking where the movie winds up I
feel like there's just too much that's
effective and worth appreciating that
walk out of it there were some real
intense moments in there and it was very
jarring offered one of them the best
shock scare jump scares of the year like
jaw dropper yeah yeah one that like
many a jump-scare experiences but who I
can't recall the last time other than
hereditary that had a moment where my
job was just draw for a significant
amount of time I was like I can't
believe it's very visceral very like you
leave that movie feeling like you just
ran a mile and got in a really [ __ ]
argument with somebody and more so than
a quiet place I totally understand why
there's an uproar against the fact that
this movie has received zero Golden
Globe nominations oh yeah
I mean at least for a Tony :
I think cinematography and Colet yeah
both of those like is it's insanely
surprising to me and I know they don't
do cinematography Golden Rose but for
Toni Collette especially that's a shot
yeah I mean you know there are a million
ways to look at snubs and there are
inevitably just more movies than you can
nominate every year but this of all the
things this year perhaps this feels like
the most of us just as yeah flat outs no
I'm just like Richard did not see this
movie yeah catch the way that she led
the whole film yeah yeah this is good
list watch more just least divisive list
it was a little shaky there at the
outset but you tied it to you yeah Eric
Horseman thanks so much for requesting
this buddy
I know lately even going through a
really rough time and I can't imagine
that the holidays are making it any
easier this shitty part when you're
going to rough time is when it's
supposed to be a time of just so much
love and happiness so I can really
identify with that I'm sorry you're
currently having some rough patches but
know that people out there like myself
and John do you love him of course you
better we'll love you so much I
definitely love you we have long
exchanges on patreon I think about you
all the time
whoa just be genuine
I'm sorry I think about you sometimes
don't be a dick
I've thought about you a few times
usually when I see your name on the
patreon page and then we start talking
there you go in the compass I love you
because we talk so much and I really
care about you and I want you to feel
better buddy for this Christmas I'm
going to peer pressure you into finally
getting that real rejects tattoo yeah
you don't get it I'm blocking you on our
patreon page you better get it soon and
by the way any money you throw down to
get that tattoo do not take it out of
your pledge for the month very import of
December you know in fact if you want to
just take that money for the tattoo and
put it to increase the play that's
that's an option not saying you have to
just draw on yourself you could just do
that shop they would patreon I love you
subscribe to the real rejects like that
notifications valve takes off it's your
TV show reactions q and A's Jon does
music video coverage I show my butt bye